[Musique]
à Châteauroux Douchka alias taillebass a
vite compris que la différence était une
force une opportunité taille basse c'est
un mètre 22 d'audace d'enthousiasme de
joie de vivre et d'humour qui a su
capitaliser plus d'un million de
followers aujourd'hui je vais à sa
rencontre pour que pour qu'elle
m'explique comment on l'a fait parce que
moi aussi je suis différent moi j'étais
le seul noir de mon village et j'ai que
100000 abonnés j'ai pas un million de
followers
bonne réponse c'est vrai qu'on a quand
même beaucoup de choses en commun
c'est quoi la technique pour augmenter
ses abonnés et pour faire des vues moi
j'utilise souvent les trend donc en fait
c'est les tendances actuelles par
exemple une musique une musique tendance
bah tu fais une chorégraphie sur la
musique et l'algorithme il va être en
faveur c'est parti tout de suite une
danse Kamini featuring taille basse
[Musique]
nickel grâce à toi peut-être je vais
être en tendance sur Tik Tok je compte
sur toi alors je dis quoi je dis Douchka
ou taibas tu préfères quoi toi
aussi tu as grandi dans un petit village
exactement ok bon on va commencer la
compétition combien d'habitants toi 400
c'est vraiment petit village moi j'étais
le seul noir de mon école seulement au
club de foot tu imagines comment ça
s'est passé pour moi mais donc on a des
similitudes raconte-moi un petit peu toi
ta jeunesse alors j'étais sûrement la
sale naine mais à la seule personne de
petite taille mais la plus heureuse je
pense comment ça s'est passé ou un peu
le début de cette histoire là c'est réel
parce que c'est parti de rien suite au
premier confinement donc j'étais en
télétravail donc un réel ennui et j'ai
voulu poster une vidéo avec mon chien
pour me distraire et distraire tout le
monde et je pensais pas qu'elle allait
avoir autant de succès entre guillemets
parce que 3 millions de vues et il y a
eu 2000 commentaires c'était énorme et
retrouve tout de suite la première vidéo
Tik Tok de taille basse Kamini
journaliste emporter France 3 le noir
[Musique]
la première vidéo fonctionne comment tu
comment tu fais pour la deuxième tout de
suite tu fonces tu enchaîne tu doutes au
début j'ai eu peur parce que je me suis
dit comment je vais gérer tout ça et en
fait dans tous ces commentaires j'ai eu
beaucoup de questions sur mon mode de
vie donc les gens s'interrogeaient
tel ou telle chose et tout machin
complètement il y a quand même une image
d'une analyse assez dévalorisante donc
je voulais absolument te montrer qu'on
est des gens comme tout le monde j'ai
pris un cours de traîne toi tu vas
prendre un cours de rap j'ai fait une
chanson en entraîneur pour les gens
différents ça s'appelle ce qui est petit
et mignon
[Musique]
ce qui est petit est mignon
c'est mignon ce qui est le petit est
mignon c'est mon divin masser à cause
des grands
cabini représente Château Rouge le menu
Château Rouge le menu
illes font des bruits comme ça dans les
boissons je te jure c'est vrai
regarde comment on a géré c'est
incroyable franchement ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas fait autant de
millions de vues sur les réseaux
merci
taille basse merci à toi je suis